during World War two the British
military performed a secret operation
where they took a corpse from a London
morgue dressed it as a drowned soldier
and planted it on a beach in Spain for
the enemy to find it was the greatest
act of deception ever achieved in modern
warfare the operation was called
mincemeat and this is how its story goes
it's 1943 the Allies are on the verge of
a Mediterranean invasion of Europe but
in order for such an invasion to be
successful they must deceive their
German enemies about where exactly it
will take place to do this Lieutenant
Commander you and Montague and Flight
Lieutenant Charles shall Mon delay
devise a plan that would allow the
Germans to accidentally intercept false
invasion plans in their plan a plane
crashed British soldier would wash up on
the beach in Spain where the government
is known to cooperate with the Germans
the body they used had to be a
relatively young recent death with no
living relatives or injuries that
indicated other cause of death they find
these qualities in a 34 year old Welsh
man named Glenn de Vere Michel who had
just committed suicide by rat poison in
a London warehouse they then create a
fake life story for this soldier who
never existed Glenn beer becomes Major
William Martin he's known to his friends
as Bill he carries a picture of his
fiancee Pam two love letters from her
and a receipt from a jeweler for an
engagement ring with the engraving - Pam
from WM he's given a pair of good woolen
underwear very hard to come by due to
rationing luckily a professor at Oxford
has just been killed by a truck and they
were able to obtain his he wears a
silver crucifix and his st. Christopher
medallion in hope that the Spanish will
believe he's a Roman Catholic and
refrain from performing an autopsy in
his pockets or a letter from his father
an overdraft notice from Lloyds Bank a
pencil stub he's a used bus ticket
ticket stubs from a theatre and a bill
for four nights stay at a hotel all of
which are fake to his wrists is chained
a briefcase containing false documents
alluding to an invasion of Greece and
Sardinia within those fake plans are
hints that the Allies would attempt a
mincemeat style act of deception where
the Germans would be tricked into
thinking the attack would come in Sicily
which is actually where the real one
will take place in his Royal Marines
uniform major Martin is placed in his
steel canister filled with dry ice
driven to holy Loch Scotland by Aston
Martin race car driver John horse fall
and load
it onto the submarine hms sarah at 4:30
a.m. on April 30th its surface off the
coast of 12a Spain where a known German
agent was stationed major Martin was
fitted with a life jacket red navel
burial rites and pushed into the sea in
time his body would be found turned over
to the Germans who would take the bait
divert their armies from Italy as well
as from the Eastern Front
an unforeseen response to the ruse that
had even greater effect on sealing the
fate of the enemy and the course of the
war
[Music]